l'effet se sont déroulés à proximité de
cet arrêt de bus il est environ 17h hier
quand un jeune garçon d'une quinzaine
d'années agressent violemment à coups de
couteau de cuisine deux sœurs âgées de
12 et 15 ans elle venait juste de
descendre de leur bus en provenance de
leur collège de Paron et s'apprêtait à
regagner leur domicile si tu es quelques
mètres plus loin la plus âgée des deux
jeunes filles n'est que légèrement
touché sa soeur est plus gravement
atteinte elle a reçu une dizaine de
coups de couteau mais elle est hors de
danger un acte de violence qui suscite
encore aujourd’hui une forte vague
d'émotions dans ce village tout le monde
est bouleversé moi la première on
s'attend pas dans un village aussi calme
que naïe de de rencontrer une violence
pareille ils sont de parois et son ils
sont connus et
après c'est très apprécié de la commune
donc je sais que les voisins sont
très près d'eux l'agresseur présumée
n'est pas du village mais des témoins
nous ont confirmé l'avoir vu rôder dans
le secteur en vélo c'est d'ailleurs sur
son vélo qu'il prendra la fuite avant
d'être interpellé blessé quelques mètres
plus loin l'hypothèse du dépit amoureux
est évoqué mais pas encore confirmé par
le parc et d'Auxerre chargé de l'enquête
un profil psychiatrique de l'adolescent
a été demandé dans l'attente des
résultats et pour les besoins des
investigations la garde à vue du jeune
homme a été prolongée